hi everyone
it gives me great pleasure to invite you
all to our continuing monthly
inference colloquium series these talks
followed by discussion sessions the next
day are part of our larger intellectual
project
on trying to understand the nature of
causation correlation
and inference across disciplines
our series as many of you may know
has comprised talks by eminent scholars
whose domains of expertise span
physics philosophy of science
mathematics
and including in the coming months talks
by a biologist and organizational
behavior expert
and a computer scientist the goals of
our project
are to really understand how we infer
from models
the power and the limits of models as
inferential
engines and i'm really excited that
today's speaker
is the philosopher of science whose work
is centered on physics
dr elise krull whose talk is titled no
cause for concern
indefinite causal ordering as a tool for
understanding
entanglement and i'm delighted that our
conversant with dr krall tomorrow's
discussion
session is the eminent philosopher of
science professor yamima ben
menahem from the department of
philosophy the hebrew university of
jerusalem we are absolutely delighted to
have
both of them participate in the sequence
of events
but before we start today's presentation
i would uh and i introduced dr krell i
would like to recognize
our benefactors mr and mrs richard and
barbara frankie whose generosity
in setting up this unique
interdisciplinary program
and many other activities at yale have
greatly enriched the campus and the
university's mission
also i need to remind those of you who
are assembled here today that we are
recording this event
and that all participants must therefore
mute their videos
and as per usual please feel free to
submit questions through the chat
feature for the q a session at the end
of uh
the talk now to introduce professor
elise krull who
is a faculty member at the department of
philosophy in the city university of new
york
after studying physics and astronomy at
calvin university a very robust and good
intellectual
background i might add i'm joking of
course i say this
as an astrophysicist myself uh that
professor krul took the plunge
into interdisciplinary borders earning
both an m.a and a phd in the history and
philosophy of science
from the university of notre dame before
coming to cuny in 2014
she held postdoctoral positions at the
university of aberdeen and at the hebrew
university's
edelstein center for history and
philosophy of science technology and
medicine
where she spent many blissful hours
huddled over documents in the einstein
archives oh gosh i'm envious while most
of her research to date concerns
historical and philosophical foundations
of quantum mechanics
role is also drawn to questions in sort
of this hinterland between contemporary
metaphysics and physics
these are the really profound and
complex questions
that have been very very hard to even
methodologically approach
and elise has made enormous headway in
many of these important questions
in particular she is interested in the
philosophical implications of
entanglement
and quantum d coherence how these
phenomena
modify traditional views about the
structure of space
time and what explanatory roles they
might play within various
approaches to an emerging theory of
quantum gravity
so without further ado elise the floor
is yours
how does everything look looks great
well thank you for that generous
introduction priya
and thank you for the invitation also
priya and tai to be a part of this
really wonderful very deeply and
genuinely interdisciplinary
um colloquium on inference and causation
and i also want to say thank you to the
franks just for their center
such scholarship encouraging it among uh
undergraduates and graduates and
faculty is it's just like the beating
heart of the academy i think
so thank you for your endeavors to
create these sorts of spaces for us
so today i'll be speaking about um
the lack of causality or indefiniteness
in causality uh hence no cause
for concern um i've subtitled it
indefinite causal ordering as a tool for
understanding entanglement
but i'll in fact be saying something a
little bit broader than that
not just about understanding
entanglement where i'll make some
provisional gestures but really just
thinking
thinking about indefinite causal
ordering of quantum processes
carefully and understanding what this
new physics might
uh how it might inform various
discussions in
quantum information quantum computation
quantum gravity
uh non-relativistic quantum mechanics
and of course in philosophy of physics
so let's dive in okay
and apologies in advance if my cat
wanders by he just loves
entanglement um so i would like to begin
by setting the stage
just giving you a quick sneak peek
of one small part of a vast
philosophical literature and causation
um and then by giving you a sneak peek
of the discussion that's happening
around causality in physics
just a little bit and then i'll give you
a plan for the talk
and we'll we'll we'll go on so here is
just
the brief um setup now uh
matthias frisch has just in the last i
think
10 months written a stanford
encyclopedia of philosophy entry on
causation
in physics and i highly recommend it i
believe there's a link
on the website to his article
it's just a very clear taxonomy of the
problems and discussions and debates
through history
but one thing he does which is really
nice is characterize the causation
discussion and philosophy as
being groups of projects that may have
overlapping but a little bit separable
um aims so there are metaphysical
projects projects that want to think
about causation and what it implies
about
the way the world really is and what is
cause what does cause mean about spatial
temporal relations
what level in the ontological hierarchy
should causal
processes exist in and so on
um there are also descriptive and
uh sort of descriptive projects
that want to understand what is it that
physicists are actually doing
when they invoke cause or causal
processes or causal laws
in particular theories um and then
there's also the functional aim
how does cause help us make inferences
how does cause
help us link up different phenomena
regimes of phenomena and so on so
that's a quick parsing of the
philosophical space
and yamima has written a lovely book
um that came out a couple years ago
called causation and science and she is
not
primarily concerned with the
metaphysical project i believe
um but we'll let her say more about that
tomorrow um i will be today thinking
as the first way in about metaphysics
right and in this uh and in this
direction
there are sort of three camps right and
here they are listed
there are causal fundamentalists um i
know we get sort of skeeved out by the
word fundamentalist but here it just
means that
causal laws are a fundamental part of
the universe
so if we find some grand unifying theory
whatever law sits
in that theory as sort of the basic law
will be a causal law
um or it could be a thesis that says
there exists some universal causal
principle
and this was historically motivated for
a lot of reasons because we look at the
world around us it seems that
events are causally related to one
another and how do we do science we do
science by
um exploring such connections or such
relations
so these two theses come out of a
classical understanding of the world
um but in recent times there have been
these other views
namely the causal limitivist view which
was maybe made most famous by john
norton in the last few decades
and causal limitativism is just a denial
of
fundamentalism they say look there is no
fundamental
causal principle maybe cause
pops in here and there in our
descriptions or it's a functional tool
that we use to build our theories and
make predictions and so on but it isn't
a part of the
actual structure of the world so norton
wants to go even further than just
eliminating
um cause from our from the bottom level
he wants to say that cause only ever
appears
in a sort of emergent fashion and where
it appears
when we are using that term cause um
it can always be reduced whatever law
or relationship is being described with
that term
can be reduced to a law or relationship
that is fundamentally
non-causal in other words what looks
like causal at the operational
functional level disappears or reduces
into something that is ultimately
non-causal right so causal limitivists
let's eliminate cause it's a pretty
strong position
um somewhere between the last two camps
are the non-fundamentalists and
if you're philosophers you've heard
about the human controversy right the
humans
uh tend to be the non-fundamentalists
and they deny
that um both of the theses that there
exists a universal causal principle
uh and they also want to say that causal
laws do not exist as part of the
fundamental gnomic structure or law-like
structure of the universe
um but they're gonna disagree with the
eliminativist too by saying that
causal structures or causal talk can
still play robust
or genuine roles in explaining or maybe
there are some
or some views where causality does
properly emerge
at some higher level of your ontology
but it isn't at the fundamental level
fundamental level is just
a human mosaic if you will
so those are the three camps
um and i'll be looking at the physics
and then sort of
asking what the physics has to say
maybe about these three camps if it
informs our discussion in any way
all right so what's the discussion over
in physics um
there are a few types of responses
crudely categorized once again
of course causal assumptions are crucial
for classical modeling and in classical
theories
but it's been understood for quite some
time that quantum mechanics allows for
non-causal situations whether non-causal
is equivalent to
a causal or just indefinite
causally ordered situations will be a
question we ask
later on but
there are a variety of approaches right
there are there are those theorists
usually who say look
um yes it's possible that there is um
a lack of causal structure or there's
some kind of indefinite causal ordering
ico um that exists
at the bottom level in our quantum
theories or whatever
but nevertheless um what this should
inspire us to do
is to develop causally neutral quantum
formalisms
or on the other hand develop measures
for
how non-causal certain structures are
right um so maybe this is just a way of
saying we should divorce
our quantum formalism from the
assumption of a background space-time or
a background
uh causal apparatus of some sort so i
believe that like
archery fields um causally neutral
formalism is sort of of that vein
um another formal response would be okay
so at the bottom level we have
indefinite causal ordering
but perhaps there are formalisms we can
develop or tools we can develop that
allow us to recover
causal structure and that also is being
done for instance by
costas and shrapnel who developed
uh um a causal markovian condition for
quantum systems
uh so they they these these people
are less interested in the metaphysical
question of why we don't see
cause at the bottom level or should we
be seeing it or whatever and we're just
saying okay given that we have
uh the possibility of weird causal
situations from quantum mechanics
how can we adjust the framework or the
formalism up here so we can go on with
our modeling
tasks or enhance our modeling tasks
there has been an experimental response
um
some of which is to say okay this this
lack of causal ordering
can be a way for us to increase
efficiency in quantum computation or
information
technology or uh information information
theory or
quantum communications right um and this
has already been done
and i'll discuss a paper where uh
indefinite causal ordering has in fact
more efficiently uh allowed for this um
the computation of some specific problem
as opposed to a causally ordered uh
superposition of a quantum
circuit um okay there's
also a theoretical response that says
well let's
let's look at this lack of causal
ordering and use it to ask those deeper
questions about fundamental features
or fundamental properties of the
universe from quantum theory
so as schrodinger said in his
uh entanglement paper for the cambridge
society in 1935
uh entanglement is not one but the
characteristic property that causes
departure from classical theories
so entanglement is quantumness in
essence
and there are some ethereal work
theoretical work or
proposed experiments that use indefinite
causal ordering
to understand or probe entanglement in
various
situations um so that's very cool so it
might shed
we might be able to use indefinite
causal ordering to shed some light on
these old questions about the properties
the underlying properties of the world
from quantum mechanics we might also
use it in our future theorizing and not
just to understand
uh quantum mechanics per se but maybe we
can look at the lack of causal order
ordering as motivating certain um
efforts to quantize um general
relativity or to quantize gravity
um over others and so i'll have more to
say about that in the future so
a lot of responses from the physics as
well and we'll zoom in on a few of these
that will um feed i hope into a
metaphysical type
thesis so plan of the talk pretty
typical philosophy of physics sort of
talk
i'm going to start by looking at some of
the physics right
i'll ask sort of three look at three
things here
first i'll briefly discuss um since this
is an interdisciplinary audience
why would we expect indefinite causal
ordering in quantum processes in the
first place
and once we've covered that ground i'll
look at a particular
experimental case uh the quantum switch
and the quantum switch is a way of um
measuring degrees of non-causal
uh correlation right among processes
so it's very cool um and then i'll look
at a relativistic case
so this is um an experiment
uh well a theoretical experiment
presented by
uh henderson who's uh she's at i think
waterloo
and co-workers uh and there they're
looking at how
i have a quick question sure is there a
reason you are using the word process
rather than events uh
yes that will become a little bit
clearer when we get into the
the details of the quantum switch thank
you yeah thank you
um so henderson and her colleagues have
been looking at quantum field theory
uh entangling detectors that are coupled
to the field
and using it to harvest entanglement and
they they've
found some preliminary very interesting
um
both um more efficacious
um ways of coupling detectors in a
non-causal superposition
um they can harvest uh more entanglement
with that kind of superposition among
their detectors uh and also they raised
some very interesting questions about
what does it really mean
to have the detectors which are physical
things presumably
in superpositions that are physical
states presumably
uh that nevertheless yield these strange
sort of
backwards forward superpositions okay
so look at the physics first and then
the second part will be just sort of
drawing out some of the consequences of
this
physics and this is the part where i'm
uh doing totally
new stuff here with you all now and so
i'd love to have lots of discussion with
you all about it
so again i'll sort of look at the at the
the quantum switch
and what it might imply or not imply
about causation
in quantum physics uh and then i'll look
uh at the case of entanglement
harvesting in qft
and um sort of have have a think about
what that might mean
and then part three is very quick it's
just where i'm going to make some
talk sized uh theses right the specific
toxized thesis about causality and
quantum theories
what can we say given um ico
as an active area of theoretical and
experimental research right now
what can we conclude about causality and
quantum but also maybe in physics more
generally
maybe right and then a general thesis
which isn't about physics alone but as a
back to that question i started with
about the metaphysics of causation
itself
um have any uh has any of the physics
that i go through
has it modified or made easier or more
difficult
um certain aspects or defenses for those
three
main approaches to the metaphysics of
causation the
the human non-fundamentalist account the
non-human
uh sort of fundamentalist account and
then the eliminativists
right okay here we go
so uh the physics
why do we so the question why do we
expect um indefinite causal ordering in
quantum
processes in the first place um
well in the literature and uh
and i think there's some care that needs
to be taken from philosophers here too
because in the literature it's very
quickly said by the physicists that
there are well there are sort of these
two reasons
that come from the formalism of quantum
mechanics that lead us to expect
uncertainty with respect to everything
including
causal properties um but maybe also
the experimental violation of bell
inequalities tells us also something
about causality
um but as i note two thirds of the way
down the page there
um there there may be different notions
of
non-classical causal structure being uh
implied by these different things so
keep that in mind so here's the theory
reason number one it's just the
superposition principle right
uh we do quantum mechanics in hilbert
space
and one of the properties of hilbert
space is the superposition principle
namely if
psi one is a solution a possible state
for some system or
a process that a system that systems can
undergo
and psy2 is likewise a solution an event
process then any or any linear
combination of them is also a solution
so you've probably heard this described
in the double slit experiment uh if
passage of an electron or a photon
through one slit is a possible solution
it is uh and passage through the other
site is a possible solution
it is then a superposition of passage
through slit one and slit
two is also a possible solution a
possible state
that the electron could have or the
photon right
so what this means for causal processes
is that
it's possible that there's um
[Music]
a state but state here is broader than
state before because it characterizes
not
a an event but a process right resulting
from two ordered
simple operations so you could have a
process
where operation a happens first then
operation b happens
and that process is in a superposition
with the process where b
happens first and then a now notice i've
left
um it vague in this setup whether
there's a causal relationship between a
and b
or whether it's just a temporal
relationship
and that will make a difference when we
get to the entanglement harvesting
quantum field theory work by henderson
and colleagues
so prima facie the superposition
principle
would suggest that superpositions of
processes are possible
in the same way that superpositions of
states are possible
theory theoretical reason number two is
the uncertainty principle you know
heisenberg's uncertainty principle
um that there's uh there are a there's a
bound
on them the precision precision with
which
uh canonical variables can be uh
commuting variables rather can be
uh simultaneously measured
um the question that many of the
physicists begin their paper with who
are doing ico is well if there's
uncertainty regarding property classical
properties like position and momentum
and velocity
then it stands to reason that causality
which is sort of a meta relation a
relation that comes
out of the relative space and time
and momentum and velocity of of the
systems in question
then surely there's uncertainty at that
level as well
um and here's my little note about a
maybe there's a different kind of
uncertainty that arises due to causal
superpositions a superposition of one
causal ordering with a superposition of
another causal warning that seems to be
uh a different state of affairs than
just saying that there's
indefiniteness or that there's
uncertainty
in some causal process
so uh right hi cat are you weighing in
good uh the experimental reason for
expecting
indefinite causal ordering and quantum
processes is just
ye old bell's inequalities right
if you have an epr pair of entangled
particles and you send them shooting off
in some different directions you have
spatially separated detectors
um and you measure sort of the
correlation between
i don't know polarization of those
photons and you look at the statistics
the the amount of times they agree or
disagree um
you know classical probability gives you
some
uh upper bound of how often you would
expect them to degree when you set the
detectors to different angles and so on
um bell's inequality says look uh if
there's a if there's a correlation
greater than this amount uh then it just
can't be described by
uh classical processes right so there's
already causal notions
packed into the bell inequality and
as many of you are well aware um
interpreting
what bell um tests mean
about locality or separability or
entanglement or causation
has not only spawned new interpretations
of quantum mechanics
but spawned a robust literature so it's
it's a complex question but the very um
rough idea that bell's theorem provides
a bound
on what a local theory should be able to
describe versus what a non-local theory
um would give rise to is sort of um
considered by many ico physicists to be
analogous to what they're trying to do
they want to find bounds
that that tell tell them whether
processes are existing
in causal or non-causal orders okay
so a little bit of the
background here the basic theory of a
quantum switch
um and so just if you don't remember
quantum qubit is just
a two-state quantum system so like a
spin half particle or something
so imagine we've got two two-qubit state
and they're the two-qubit state
composite state capital psi
where you've got a control qubit c and a
target qubit
phi t and they live in a joint hilbert
space all that's pretty normal quantum
mechanics
but now we can we can set up uh
set up a scenario where we condition two
different operations operation a
which could just be a measurement in a
lab and operation
b uh and apply them to our target state
um so depending on what value the
control state has
the target state will be operated on
in a different order so we might
categorize this down here as bottom
that if um if the
if the control state is at value zero
right
um or in state zero or spin up if you
will
then we're going to perform the
operation a first then
b on our target qubit but
if the control qubit is in i don't know
the other states
so spin down maybe then we're going to
perform the operations in the in the
reverse order on our target qubit
so we just went through the
superposition principle
should be pretty obvious that if the
control qubit is able to be in
zero or one then it follows that it's
possible that it's in a superposition
of zero in one right maybe a maximally
in like
a nicer position right here uh and what
results from this
is the superposition of operations so
you have the
the process first a then b in a
superposition with the process first
b then a um and note that
this superposition of processes um
is itself right a superposition but also
is itself entangled with
the control qubit state so it's
non-separable already
and so this really interesting little
image but i think it's helpful is from
rubino at all
and rubino and his colleagues were the
first as far as i know to experimentally
uh directly verify the existence
of indefinite causal ordering uh and so
here we've got our process matrix at the
bottom w
oh i don't have a point can you see my
pointer
well yeah i believe so at least you can
okay yes all right so uh at the bottom
of each of these three panes which are
three different scenarios
um we have the the the w
the process matrix w which which tells
us
what the what the path was what the
order was for the target qubit
so here's where we're saying the control
qubit is in state
zero or spin up if you wish uh in which
case
the target qubit is first we'll say that
this is alice
alice is in her in you know independent
lab uh in
england and she does a measurement on
target cubit and then sends it
over to bob and bob is in uh istanbul
and bob does the measurement and uh
he performs process p on it and then we
get an output right
it could go the other direction as well
where the first bob gets the target
qubit and then alice does
uh and then this final state is the one
of interest for the quantum switch which
is when we have the control qubit in a
superposition
of those processes in which case the
target qubit
um performs the superposition
of both of the prior um processes
right so it's a it
it's unclear what ordering uh causal
ordering is going on between
uh alice and bob it's it's it's not
predetermined
by the setup i'll say that a little more
about that in a moment
um so another way to characterize this
the quantum switch
uh in a quantum switch we've got w uh
the particular ordering is is it first
does this process
a here it first sorry it goes the other
direction
um it first puts the input state through
a superposition of a and b
and that gives us some output one
parentheses
then it sends the input through a then b
which results in output two and then
through b then a resulting output three
and then it coherently recombines all of
those
outputs and that measurement is the
measurement we're interested
in it will tell us uh
what degree if any of non-causal
ordering uh
was evident between the processes a to b
then b
to a so
um in order to unders uh underst to make
this measurement
uh or uh quantify the degree of
uh entanglement or non-separability
between
these causal states or causal processes
forgive me
um the physicists build a causal witness
which is a which is an operator that's
supposed to be analogous to an
entanglement witness
so just in case you don't know
entanglement witness is just a hermitian
operator
that when it acts on some composite
system will give you a density matrix
when you carry out the trace of
of that composite system with the
operator acting on it if the trace is
less than zero you can conclude that the
subsystem was
uh subsystems are entangled uh and to
what degree
uh and if the trace is greater than or
equal to zero then you conclude that the
subsys
that the composite system was separable
so analogously um
but instead of using a density matrix
here we want to use the process matrix w
and so here's the difference between a
density matrix and
states right uh with
um a process matrix w and processes
so a causal witness then is just a a
uniquely
a specially defined hermitian operator
that acts on the process matrix
w uh and it just which describes the
state of the operations
uh and again it yields a trace of less
than zero if the processes
um it's witnessing are causally
separable so we can say um
that a then b happen first then b then a
happened or vice versa
um but the measure is greater than or
equal to zero
um if they're entangled and i believe it
is
flipped like that like so it's less than
zero uh less than zero if they're
separable and greater than equal to zero
if they're entangled
um and so of course much like with the
bell inequalities you can come up with
sort of this upper bound
uh or with these limitations for what
you expect for degrees of entanglement
between these causal
processes um and the
experimental agreement is high so just
to back up a little bit
um and maybe put this in slightly more
layman's terms i suppose uh arreshkov
and his colleagues in 2012 sort of gave
a theoretical picture of what this
um what this process matrix might be
like and they assume that they
there's this game between alice and bob
i mean bob has some strategy
where he's gonna get um his system he's
gonna receive it from alice
and if what he receives from alice is a
particular state then he's gonna do a
particular kind of measurement
uh and if it's a different kind of state
then he'll do a different kind of
measurement
so his uh output is conditional on
alice's and so on so there's a causal
connection
between what bob does the measurement he
does
uh and what alice is doing over in her
lab
um and so ureshkov and his colleagues
calculate that if you assume
that there's a causal order that it's
it's very clear
um that
alice sends her states to um
bob he does his measurements uh and he's
successful
um conditional on the input of alice's
lab
they say that success will be
less than three-fourths of the time he's
going to be able to implement a strategy
that is successful
okay um however if they set up this
again it's it's it's like the
superposition of the causal ordering
in the quantum switch right if alice and
bob the order
that they receive each other's uh
information or states is not determined
beforehand so it's not that alice sends
a result to bob and bob makes a
conditional decision
um if it's indeterminate then in fact
bob's
rate of success at adjusting his
measurement based on
what he receives as input from alice is
higher
this is exciting because at least
foreign others it shows that perhaps if
you do
have uh indefinite causal ordering
between these two operations you can get
a higher efficiency
um you can get a success rate for
certain computations that's higher
than if you're dealing with causally
ordered um causally ordered
sets of operations and that was in fact
what was proven
in procopio at all 2013 so they
indirectly verified the indefinite
causal ordering
of a quantum switch so they didn't use a
causal witness
so they didn't get an exact measure on
the entanglement but what they did was
they showed that they could get
higher efficiency on some computation
when using a quantum circuit circuit
that was in a
causal superposition as opposed to a
circuit that was in a causally ordered
uh was causally ordered in its processes
so the teams
listed below said okay well we want to
do one better we want to implement this
causal witness schema and see if we can
directly verify
indefinite causal ordering because in a
sense what procopia at all had done is
just to show that
the superposition was more effective
than sort of separable causal
ordering um but they wanted to get quant
uh reuben at all and goswami at all
wanted to get quantitative about it
so they developed the causal witness um
and they did in fact
measure values that were in close
agreement with the theoretical
expectation
for non-separable causal processes uh so
upshot here these direct verifications
of indefinite causal ordering are
showing
um are our measurements of entangled
causal processes
of processes where order a and b is is
entangled with b
and a and so on
pretty bizarre um
i would like now to talk briefly about
what might be happening in quantum field
theory uh
and as far as i'm aware a lot of this uh
work stems from something brookner said
in a tournament 2014 paper which was
sort of a
a review of the fields uh physics and
causality right now
uh so he made this interesting
suggestion after describing the quantum
switch
saying well look we could probably do
something analogous uh using a massive
object that's in a superposition of
positions um because if they're
spatially
separated like the component states have
some spatial separation
that they're entangled over um that
means that the gravitational field that
that massive object produces will also
be in a superposition of states ergo
the space-time geometry itself will be
in a superposition
and so i have this quote from him here
that the causal succession of gate
operations in a quantum circuit or
a quantum switch uh is the analog of
events separated by a time-like interval
this analogy can be pushed further than
networks in which geometry of the wires
between the gates is entangled with the
state of the control qubit
so again the quantum switch situation
can be thought of as a toy model for the
quantum
gravity situation uh that he introduced
before
namely if you put a massive object in a
spatial superposition then the metric
that's produced in the spacious temporal
distances between the events
in the gravitational field get entangled
with the object's position
so this suggests new ways to understand
entanglement
uh at different locations in a field uh
and also
to possibly motivate or constrain the
ways we quantize
general relativity so to that
end uh very recently uh here's the
henderson at all paper that i mentioned
earlier quantum temporal superposition
the case from qft
um i'm going to be really brief on this
because i want to get to the philosophy
um quantum field theories describe
correlation between space-time points
that's what they do
so if we put like a really tiny little
like a quantum system that's a particle
detector
in the field and we couple it to the
field then it can perform measurements
on the field and can tell us about local
values it can tell us about correlations
and so on
so these um physicists ask the question
okay and you notice brookner is among
the colleagues here
um so maybe he made that um 2014
suggestion with malice of forethought um
but
question what if we put two particle
detectors
out in the field that are in a quantum
superposition and then use that
uh that composite or superposed
detectors use it to probe uh field
correlations
uh another way to say that is in
particular to harvest
entanglement to measure degrees of
correlation quantum correlation
in the field will we in analogy with a
quantum switch
find higher efficacy when the detectors
are in super pro
post states will they be able to measure
a higher degree of intent
more effectively measure entanglement
rather and it looks like that is in fact
the case
um so they they looked at two different
situations here
so they took um so on the left hand side
here they have
two different um uh detectors
that are cause in a cause effect
superposition
so it's an explicit superstition where a
will cause
some later state b in detector b and b
causes a
right whereas on the right side it's
just the past future so it's just a
temporal ordering
um a before b that is the the time that
the detector takes a measurement a
before b
and then b before a um they found some
weird er first of all like that they
could propose
this theoretically is is
quite um something because there's a
there are no go theorems about how the
signaling among the superimposed
detectors can
work and so on uh is quite a feat um
but it's interesting because they found
out that in each like in the left-hand
case in the right-hand case in this
image um you have a branch
um you have different branches of the
superposition
and while you can transform one branch
either from a cause effect superposition
to
sorry from a cause effect situation to a
past
future um you cannot ever do that so
that both branches agree
in cause effect whether they're cause
effect relations
or past future relations
um so there's sort of that interesting
way that it looks like they're able to
tell
by coupling these detectors in the right
way with the field and
their being in superposition with one
another they can differentiate between
superpositions that are just a before b
and b before a versus legitimately
uh legitimate superpositions of a causes
b
with b causes a so one of my worries
earlier
earlier on was that well just because
they're indefinitely causal or
causally ordered uh or even in a super
is not necessarily the same thing as
being in a superposition of
a causes b just as much as b causes
a if you will um but this proposed
experiment does
seem to be able to discriminate between
uh what is what i might call a genuine
superposition of
causal processes uh
and that's truly weird um
on the efficacy fronts they do find that
um that putting detectors and
superpositions in this way
allows them to be more effective um
to more effectively perform entanglement
harvesting
so just as with the quantum circuit it
was found that a superposition
of causal states was more effective for
a certain
computation here they're finding that
entanglement harvesting or just the
probing of the field for different
correlations
is more effective uh when you're dealing
with superposition of detectors as
opposed to
uh pure states of detectors okay
that's the physics it's all pretty brand
spanking new
what can we say about it um
here are some things i was thinking
about
um if we think about the proposal um
made by some of the physicists that
causality might be just another aspect
of the uncertainty relations
it's uncertain because causality is
ultimately redefined in terms of
variables at the lower level and those
variables are susceptible to uncertainty
because of quantum mechanics right
um okay maybe
but that doesn't seem to be what the
quantum switch or the
superpositions of particle detectors in
a quantum field
are seeing it's not that they're seeing
uncertainty
in the um in the ordering of processes
it's that there's they're measuring
superpositions
of well-defined causal processes
um so i'm not sure that what benefit it
might be to think about
causality as analogous to uncertain
properties like
position momentum velocity and so on um
a further problem is that the
interpretation of the uncertainty
relations
is somewhat debatable um i mean there
are limits on
whether you can assign well-defined
values
to a system before um before measurement
and those limits are described by for
instance the clock and spectrum
spectra theorem um but there are ways
that you might recover
a sort of epistemic or operational
understanding of uncertainty
where it has to do not with the nature
of the world itself
the the world itself is is just
defined perfectly clearly
um all the states are definite states
and so on and it's just that
by doing a quantum measurement on a
quantum system we introduce
disturbances of a kind that lead to
uncertainty
in various uh properties of the system
um but i wonder if there's room to make
sort of a more
metaphysical or ontological claim here
that if you do understand the
uncertainty relations is saying
something about the way the world is and
not just how we measure the world
or if you understand the way we measure
the world to be a part of the way the
world is
um maybe measurement just is defined as
weekly as
an interaction any sort of interaction
interactions are happening all the time
all over the place
um what is the nature of those
interactions i'm not sure
how we would ever determine whether ico
makes legitimate an interpretation of
causality as
fuzzy or is uncertain in this way but i
want to think more about it
um what seems more plausible and in fact
quantitatively plausible as well is that
we might be able to come up with
theorems
for measuring or gauging the quantumness
of relationships between systems
um and quantum correlations i tend to
read as
entanglement i think that's what's meant
by quantum correlations entanglement
so in this way we can um use these
bounds on causality to
understand more about entanglement
relations among different kinds of
systems
just in the same way that we've measured
spatial
entanglement using bell tests or maybe
the way that we look at temporal
uh correlations uh and gauge the
quantumness of various system
or of a system through time using legit
garg inequalities
so it's been proposed by i think
brookner was one of these
physicists that it looks like causality
uh that a process and not just um
the spatial temporal location of events
but that a series of events
might also have bounds that describe
entanglement thresholds as it were
there's a further question which um i
want to explore
which is whether causality is
recoverable is recoverable in causally
neutral formulations of qm
uh so these causally neutral
formulations do exist
they're out there um but whether they're
um
[Music]
realizable in some way and whether the
kind of causality the notion of
causality that is recoverable from them
is well what kind is it is it merely a
descriptive kind of causality
is it a loose ordering of events
um where you have certain probability
bounds like conditional probabilities
that given this event the probability
that this other event happened
prior to it is such and such okay
whether those are the kinds of causal
notions that emerge from
causally neutral formulations of quantum
theory or
whether it is some robust sense of
causality that there's really as
norton would put it sort of a factual
constraint
that's being um imposed upon the systems
we're measuring
um that is causal in nature yet doesn't
exist
at the very bottom level where we have
indefinite causal ordering
uh and then the last sort of physics-y
speculative point
um which i won't go into is
there just as bell's inequalities and
perhaps legit garg inequalities but to a
lesser extent but certainly those
inequalities
carved up the interpretations space for
non-relativistic quantum mechanics
in a very different sort of way right it
made
uh more clear the the goal of a de broil
bone
contextual hidden variables theory um
this is what the theory needed to do to
recover
um empirical data yet
um account for um
causality because to boil bone they want
to have sort of classical processes in
the background
or recover classical processes the level
of i don't know the universe maybe
um right so
maybe in the same way if we come up with
causality
inequalities based on in
indefinite causal ordering that will
shed some light on or re-carve up
the interpretation space in an
interesting way but
i suspect that the right move is not to
recarve up the space but in fact um oh
this is a general conclusion
but i'll i'll go to it now
no i won't hold on just keep it in mind
um i suspect that it will just it's just
more impetus
for ditching causality as a fundamental
aspect of
our interpretation of the world in the
first place so if you've
built as some bohmians for instance
sorry i'm picking on bohmians today
most days um if the bohmians um
have expressed like their motivation for
developing um
their pilot wave theory or their
potential hidden variables theory
was to recover um at the macro scale
classical behavior right they want their
systems
tracing out quasi-neutronian
trajectories right
um they want the world particle to be
moving deterministically that means that
the prior state is a cause
for the later state and so on
um so a large motivation for that
interpretation is to recover
classical notions among them causality
arguably um in which case
maybe this is just another reason to to
sort of avoid that interpretation
okay um another point to make very
quickly is that
um a lot of discussion about
relativistic causality
in physics and as far as i know in the
philosophical literature has focused on
signaling and the bounds placed on
signaling by
no signaling theorems and so on but i
think that these ico
processes and like the henderson at all
um detectors and superpositions in
in the field i think these are methods
of understanding or of approaching the
question of relativistic causality
uh that are not primarily about
signaling so it might be
just a different avenue for thinking
about relativistic causes causality
broadly speaking
um how are we in time oh fantastic i
shall now wrap
up um i've already mentioned some of the
relativistic consequences
namely that it gives us more specific
details about
um it gives us
uh larger regions for entanglement
harvesting
and so we just learn more about the
quantum field when we couple it
to superposed detectors in this way
um but we also asked a question and i
heard henderson in a talk she gave like
she ended the talk by saying
it looks like we're dealing with
physically
superposed detectors that have a real
effect
on um the probing of entanglement um
what does this mean uh what does this
mean for how we construct future
quantized theories
what is the what is the i think she was
asking what is the metaphysics of this
right well let's figure it out um
i've mentioned also that it motivates
attempts to develop a back
uh develop a theory of quantum gravity
or any kind of quantum
theory that is background independent so
it doesn't assume going in
that there's a set space-time manifold
or that there's causal structure
embedded uh in in
uh in the background okay so maybe
uh ooh that was i should suppose
i didn't finish editing that point but
go on to three look down at three don't
pay attention to two
um rushkov and others have suggested
that if causality like space-time should
be considered
uh dynamically emergent i mean what we
see at the macro scale is
clear causal connections do not have
um do not exist in that definite way
uh at the micro level then perhaps we
we can start building up a story about
the emergence
of those more concrete or more classical
causal structures and maybe i suggest
those are dynamical stories that involve
for instance
quantum decoherence processes um
which can effectively damp those
superpositions so that even though they
are
physically superpositions they
nevertheless are only measurable
by some other probe by an environment by
us
by a lab by else by bob as being
effectively an eigen state right so
not in a superposition um and
it might even support like canonical
approaches to quantum
gravity over covariant approaches
because um
canonical approaches because the wheeler
equation doesn't evolve in time
time has to come from somewhere and
there's some work like moravia it all
has this interesting paper
where he uh he and his team derive uh
say that even if you have a static macro
system or composite system
if you carve it up into subsystems that
are entangled with each other in the
right sort of way
they can be evolving in time and you
still have a composite state that is
static
well that's exactly the sort of thing
you want for a canonical approach to
quantum
gravity where the wheeler weight
equation is not evolving in time
um but again this uh it's possible that
a project like moravius that has to do
with recovering
time from entanglement
is is possible in terms of causal
processes as emergent from
entanglement in that way okay
so the specific thesis just it seems
that this physics
um just the fact that there are a lot of
people studying
indefinite causal processes in a variety
of ways and not just
operationally um but as what it could
tell us about
fundamental features of the world like
entanglement in quantum field theory
um that that causality either
just isn't a part of the world at the
lower level
or if it is it's indefinite but we
should become clear about
what sense it's indefinite and if there
are bounds on how
definite it is or indefinite is um and
given that we do use cause at higher
levels are these what is the nature of
these causal processes given that
there's clear evidence that
if they are emergent which they probably
are um
how does that emergence process happen
right
there's nothing causal at the
fundamental level
whence caused at this higher level um
right and then of course looking at the
relativistic
case of henderson at all we can
understand more about entanglements in
relativistic scenarios by studying
um using indefinite causal ordering as a
tool to probe
so it's not just that we've measured
indefinite causal ordering it's that
we're now using indefinite causal
ordering
to understand other parts of the
physical universe that's pretty cool
ending where i began if we look at the
three major camps for metaphysics of
causation it looks like causal
fundamentalists have an even
harder task given ico
um so for instance um the bohmians
often say that we require a primitive
tolerance ontology that has
a law that's causally a causal law
and the bohmian world particle evolves
according to that causal law
um
that seems less attractive to me given
ico
and sort of all this active research the
eliminativeness there could be serious
problems too
um because if causal talk like norton
wants is only allowed in virtue of its
being ultimately reducible to some
non-causal macro theory
well what if it's not just there's no
cause down there in this um
or that but that it's sort of entangled
causal processes
there have been arguments already in the
non-relativistic literature that you
can't have reduction
onto a base that's entangled because
entanglement is sort of a holistic
property right
um entanglement relations cannot be
further reduced
because the parts are something
different than the the whole
hello hello um and then finally i think
this comes out on top for the
non-fundamentalists um they seem to be
safe on their claim that causality does
not exist in the fundamental
makeup of the universe but it seems like
we still have
uh important uses for recovering
uh for recovering causal processes or
causal models
like the quantum markovian causal
processes at the higher level
uh quantum markovian models rather
um but i think the task may have become
slightly harder
given ico because there's maybe a larger
gap between the fundamental level and
where it is that causality comes in and
is useful
to our modeling processes okay
it's a lot very speculative can't wait
to have a discussion with you
here are very brief references thank you
very much
um thank you so much elise for this uh
wonderful talk much to think about um
and uh before i open up the floor for
questions i
wanted to uh acknowledge the fact that
you know we're delighted at least that
you are
part of our core team for this project
so excited to have you part of the
organizing team to help us
understand and i also want to give a
shout out
we have uh in the audience we have
lorenzo monyani who was one of our
previous speakers who is dialed in from
italy
and we have the person who i consider my
guru in quantum mechanics whose book i
learned from rama murthy shankar is in
the audience
and we also have peter morgan who is
thinking about these
issues who is in the audience so as well
as you know chris
mink uh so yeah you've um you've drawn
quite the crowd uh professor crowe so
so i think um and i
also have uh greetings from canada for
you
so you've had fans across the globe
um so i think i want to start with
one question that one of our again a
regular attendee
uh sanjeev kumar has and it's really a
question he has about classification
so in the consciousness only ontology
the non-causal substrate of
consciousness
becomes comparable with temporal
causation
actually i'm not sure how that is but um
that's a big claim right
does your framework tie with the
consciousness only ontology
you knew this was coming right a
question about the big s
yes i'm about to shock you all hang on
to your
chairs um i'm
not i'm not
i don't um i take it that the
consciousness only view which i'm not
super familiar with but it's still
a physicalist view yes yes i'm not a
physicalist
so i really can't answer that question
because for me consciousness
will not be ultimately describable in
physical terms and so whether or not the
physics that we do have
can adequately recover uh temporal
uh spatial causal notions um
is a very different question for me um
yeah so that's a very short answer to a
very complex question
but uh right
um i think in fact um
if there's anything that can be said
here at all if it's that uh
causations being less likely to sit at
the fundamental
level um could be used in various ways
by folks arguing for consciousness from
quantum systems right it depends on your
end game
[Music]
if causality is supposed to be a feature
of our noetic structure
right um then the fact that it's not at
the quantum level is maybe not so much
of a problem
but if all there is is consciousness um
but there isn't causality
there isn't causality at that
fundamental level then you're gonna have
to do maybe a lot more leg work to sort
of explain
whence sort of this conscious awareness
of causality that seems so natural to us
in all the sciences and not just in
physics but yeah i'm really
out of my depth talking about
consciousness to physicalists
so so i guess um
i have um something that has sort of
confused me one of the many things that
is complex and confusing
um so are you making a distinction
between entanglement being an
intrinsic property versus an emergent
property or am i
really confusing by saying that you
cannot
reduce it is that what you're saying
um so i'm thinking not in it in a
temporal sense but in the metaphysics
sense that you might um if you want to
give a totally
uh if you want to reduce the whole world
to bits and bobs that are quanta
um but these quanta exist in
entanglement relations that means
that uh my quantum system over here its
properties are not fully described by
the spatial temporal region i carve out
that contains i don't know even the
majority of the mass of that object
right if it's entangled it may have
properties that are spatially temporally
extended right um that's all i meant by
that so it's not
one sort of the non-local nature
i see yeah yeah so it has to do with
non-local absolutely
um any other questions
uh yamima if you feel free to um
ask questions today as well um we would
really greatly benefit
uh by anyone um asking thoughtful
questions
yeah can i jump in here yes uh yes
shankar please do
so uh i think the subject is very
difficult
but i do feel that if somebody could
explain it to me it is our speaker today
part that i knew
i could see how well it is explained but
that lots of it i don't know
i'm just a copenhagen hack i sort of
know the
standard way to do it in my world the
measuring instruments are of a different
size from the measured objects
and a very clear distinction between the
macroscopic world needed to define
measurements
i think in this study you're reaching a
domain where they get blurred where they
get small
so they're issues i've never thought
about but as i said
if i want to learn what those issues are
this was a very good introduction so i
got to thank her
at least for doing that i'm really
honored um can i ask you a question
while i've got
you yes i was just gonna say as a
philosopher of physics
it may not be the one you want but as a
philosopher i'm a student of don howards
who was famous among other things for
writing about the myth of the copenhagen
interpretation
sort of historically it was an
interpretation heisenberg came up with
after world war ii that aligned him more
closely with boar
moore emerged from world war ii as a
hero uh advocating glasnost and meeting
with churchill and
uh well he did work on the manhattan
project but uh
he was i don't know careful about it
um he was very conscientious um
heisenberg did not emerge from world war
ii with a similar
reputation and so it was
he made it up okay so if you
historically uh
study heisenberg's view and paulie's
view and giordan's view and einstein's
view in schrodinger's view
in the period 1926 1935 which i have a
book coming out on that
they have very rich and very nuanced
different views so here's my question
many physicists i encounter still claim
to be copenhagen
people but they're what is what does
copenhagen mean for you that there's a
distinct classical realm
or that measurement processes produce
truly definite outcomes not just
apparently or effectively definite
outcomes yeah i imagine the world
look you've got experiments going on all
the time in certain they're measuring
particles
there's a probability distribution for
where the particle will land
and if a detector is placed at that
angle and you vary the angle
that's a function that's predicted and
that seems to work
we seem to know what we mean when we
measure the pion in this detector
that's the level at which i understand
quantum mechanics the level at which it
works
okay but there detectors are huge in
fact particle theory
experimentalists never failed to show
you how big they are compared to a human
being
all their pictures have you detected in
a tiny person standing next to them
in that world the problems you say would
not arise you could never put two of
those big guys in a superposed state
right so i don't have the issues you're
raising
these are issues you you have to deal
with the issues before they come and
ruin your life but at the moment
i'm almost finished uh with my carriers
so i'm not worried about what will
happen 15 years from now
but these could be dominant issues
yeah and so i mean this is brand new
stuff for me what i have mostly done
aside from the historical and
foundational work is the coherence
studies
uh and looked at sort of that and so it
does seem clear that
at least in principle there is no
well-defined
uh domain i mean even if you take the
usual um
limiting theorems like aaron fess
theorem or
uh the louisville regime or whatever
like none of these gives a universal
description
uh that or universal classification that
slices the world where you get just
classical systems on one side and
quantum on the other whatever this may
be
you always have uh problems
um and so let's just let everything be
quantum
uh and and then let the the the dynamics
of quantum processes like the coherence
tell us why we see effectively classical
states at large like mesoscopic and
macroscopic
scales right uh and there are also
people at yale like uh
jack harris who are flirting with the
dividing line between classical and
quantum
they got mechanical objects which are
i think the largest one in which you can
see superposition
so they are cantilever oscillators which
can be in a superposed state
right it's a big enough thing that you
could probably see in a microscope but
yet it is
really in a superposed state but i
thought everyone agrees that
that is challenging but it's going to be
a long way from getting anything
substantial in a super cool state so
and that's partly the game too right
because this is
clearly a problem for quantum computing
where you want to shield your
you want to maintain the integrity of
your qubits you can only do that by
maintaining coherence
but decoherence is so damned effective
and so fast
but this is a real engineering problem
um
but if we're concerned with meta if
we're interested in the metaphysics
right the fact that we're trying to
shield systems
from losing this property indicates
something about the way nature prefers
it
as it were in sort of this quantum
entangled situation yeah
yes i agree i think i shouldn't
monopolize your time so thanks for
taking my comment and maybe i should let
other people
talk to you thank you okay i'm going to
mute myself
yeah so um there i think uh
peter did you have a question or did you
just want to
give that shout out
i guess um just a shout out you want me
to ask them just a shout out yeah
yeah please go ahead yeah yeah so just
to
first of all thanks fascinating
description of all these new
developments
and and we can talk about the
metaphysics or what is causation
tomorrow but
i was just thinking about
backwards causation or retrocausation
and you could understand what you
described
or certainly entanglements there were
ideas about
explaining entanglement in terms of
retro causality
and what you said you never mentioned
the term but what you said
seems to be compatible with that in some
cases
so what is your what is a connection
between what you said and what those
interpreters of quantum mechanics who
accept
retroposition as an explanation
well you mean the thanks i hope that's
something we can talk about it more
length
tomorrow and that's i i sort of
intentionally left it out today
um i i waved at it from a distance when
i talked about the different
like maybe that there's some uh there's
the lack of clarity about whether we're
talking about
causal processes that are causally
ordered and it's just unclear
of course a superposition of a
legitimate a
cost b but then b cost a and
retrocausality would only really
apply to part of one of those situations
uh and so in a sense if we can sort out
what a superposition of causal processes
really means
that will illuminate how much overlap
if any there is with the retrocausal
literature
um but retrocausality uh so one of the
figures historical figures i've done a
lot of work on is greta germain who
wrote
like the greatest and maybe the first
philosophical treatise on quantum
mechanics in 1935
and she she's a continent so she wants
to preserve
a fundamental causal principle but she
does this by first teasing apart
as as you well know yami and as you do
so nicely in the introduction to your
book
uh determination and prediction
as a separate thing and the existence of
a chain
of cause and effect um and there is a
chain of cause and effect she says in
quantum mechanics we just cannot
know it beforehand we can know it
retrodictively
so there's it's not retro causality but
sort of retrodiction
of something that already existed in the
world um
is sort of her way of maintaining the
causal completeness of quantum mechanics
um but yeah i know hugh price and others
have done really interesting work on
retro causality and if retro causal
thesis still require
a particular causal ordering of events
it's just not in the order we
are used to or experience that's a
different thing than saying
that it's a it's a one over square root
two superposition
of a cos b and b cos a like what does
that mean
so i hope we can talk about that more
tomorrow and you could teach me some
things about retro causality
yeah great so i just wanted to read out
a couple of shout outs before
uh moving on to the next question so um
lorenzo manyani
said as uh provided a reference on some
ideas about physics of consciousness
he refers to the area of studies called
the so-called dissipative brain
for example there's an um a chapter in a
volume
understanding brain and consciousness by
vittelo vitello and he's given the
reference for anyone who wants it in the
chat
and uh peter morgan gave a shout out for
don howard's 2004 paper
pointing out the difference between bohr
and heisenberg on the nature of
that's a clock that's a wonderful paper
uh um
and he's mentioning that it was
formative for him
uh it was quite the paper to plow
through but it's uh excellent
so um i think uh freddos has um
who's another of our regular attendees
and fellow astrophysicists
he has a very nice question which is
sort of where i was going next to
that he says you mentioned decoherence
and that your thesis work was based on
it can you elaborate a little bit more
on how this may have influenced your
developing the ideas
for example that you presented today
sure uh well um
decoherence comes is due to entanglement
so there's a a deep mother-daughter
relationship between entanglement
and decoherence and there's also a lot
of metaphysic or there's a lot of
philosophical
interest but also confusion about both
of these properties
well excuse me entanglement as a
property
that systems might have and degrees of
it and
as it evolves through time and
decoherence as a temporal pro
as a dynamical process um so i've been
thinking for a long time about
entanglement
in that guys um how it gives rise to
and how it's not evident at the meso and
macro scale
because of like a lot of puzzles having
to do with entanglement
i think can be given explanations via d
coherence
um so that's the relationship between
entanglement and and and decoherence
but also of course these questions have
to do with the quantum to classical
transition
and because i'm interested in talking to
metaphysicists
metaphysicians i think they go by
metaphysicians but it ought to be
metaphysicists
um i'm interested in understanding
ontology but in a way where um it
captures our best physics right in our
best
physics says that there's no hard and
fast way to carve up the universe
uh into classical and quantum or even
individual or closed or isolated systems
uh you're talking about dissipation well
dissipation is a big problem right
um the fact that we can effectively deal
with eigenstates or that we effectively
measure
um with pointers you know a particular
value for our measurement outcome
um that there is a quantum process
underlying those classical phenomena
uh it was really something i wanted to
understand now causality is a little bit
higher uh because the is sort of leaping
a step because i want to think a little
bit entanglement is a process across
space and time
and if you think about because we're in
a 4d or more
world right so when we talk about
entanglement relations even when we call
it
the measuring of spatial correlations in
a bell type experiment
we're in fact already doing causal
entanglement because those detectors are
at space-time
locations and so just getting clear
about um i started to ask about the
legit garg inequalities and what they
really
have to say about temporal correlations
and how we define macro
versus micro versus meso systems and so
on
and from spatial correlations and
temporal collations came
causality uh and then also priya asked
me to give a talk
on causality so that's a long-winded
answer to your question but
um yeah so i'm new to the causality
that's one of the reasons i'm
extraordinarily honored and excited to
have yamima
um have a conversation with with us
tomorrow because she is an
expert on causation and science and in
physics
uh and will bring a lot a lot more fruit
from what i've said i hope yeah no and
and i think that
you know uh thank you so much because i
think the thing that um
is confusing to a lot of us is this idea
of
determinism causation transparency of
causes
chains of causation all these things are
really
hard to kind of clearly parse out
when we are trying to understand you
know you look at a model and you're
trying to figure
out a chain of causation and what all
you can infer from you know model given
the priors that have gone into
constructing the model to start with
right so
yeah that was yeah really um looking
forward to it
um are there any other um questions
uh from the floor let's um let me just
take a look at the chat to see if
anything else
has uh i don't think anything else has
come in premium
okay great so um i think at this point
uh we should just then wrap up with uh
looking forward to
tomorrow's um really wonderful
discussion
where uh we can learn more uh thank you
elise so much for a
really really nice talk um and um
i mean i'm uh sort of tempted to ask a
question which i will pose to both of
you tomorrow which is you know what do
you really make of the prospects uh the
claim prospects for quantum computing
um you know and um whether um
are we being uh extremely optimistic or
is that just a completely different
functional realm if you can get it to
work you get it to work it doesn't
matter if we don't understand
how it works right so i guess we'll
get to that uh tomorrow thank you
everyone for attending and i want to say
a big thanks to tai
once again for helping um with
uh managing and arranging uh
this entire series and this talk and i
want to thank ryan
from um for helping us
with the recording and making um the
talks uh
available uh online so thank you
everyone have a lovely evening and see
you all tomorrow afternoon at the same
time so
3 p.m est bye
thank you